this video is sponsored by crossing void
global hi there do you need a break from
jackin it two big fat anime monster girl
titty well do I have the thing for you
crossing void Global's an all-star
turn-based mobile RPG with over 50
characters from 25 plus anime franchises
including SEO index da da da da tour
odorous by some wolf or emo and many
more that's right with so many
franchises coming together you might
even be able to say that it's the most
ambitious RPG project ever be attempted
on my all your favorite characters are
here with all their iconic moves that
you can collect via the Gacha system the
cross world collaborations allow you to
combine attacks and also allow for
unique interactions hey are you feeling
down because you can't make it to
Coachella this year to see you renowned
popstar Hatsune Miku performing live
well you're in luck cuz now in the month
of March they are having a special hats
May Miku collaboration event as Miku
Luka Rin and Len have all joined the
fray as playable characters you can
experience new banners challenging
dungeons popularity polls among virtual
singers and fun rhythm minigames is such
an exciting event let's see what
late-night American talk show host David
Letterman thinks of all this what the
[__] am I looking at click the link
below to download and now an iOS or
Android and get a free STI character or
an 8 ear Lucca today along with other
rewards and exclusive gifts from the
Miku event and now back to [__] big
titty anime monster girls into species
reviewers there's been the show that's
been tossed around every hot topic in
the discussion within the wider anime
community this season and understandably
it's a show that's pushed the boundary
further than any TV anime ever has
before and it's gotten a lot of
attention for that fact alone I'm gonna
be honest when I first saw it on the
seasonal chart and read the synopsis
about a bunch of dudes in an ISA guy not
ISA Kai fantasy world he visit Moscow
brothels to review the sex I thought to
myself brilliant this was gonna be some
great cheap me material I'd watch for
like three episodes and drop off the
novelty of the ridiculous plot line wore
off but then I actually watched it and I
was like oh
Oh No I think this is actually good I
think this show is a lot of genuine
merits behind it and a lot of it is
getting lost within the wider
conversation of other memes and
controversies so I wanted to bring the
conversation back to the show itself
because all memes aside I really do
think the show is birth to new genre to
me interspecies reviewers is one of the
most unique experiences you can find
this season and to properly explain why
we first need to answer what exactly is
this show is this an anime or a hentai
or an anti or a Hanna Mei and if it is
then why is it unavailable on Hanna made
or TV
I think everyone's initial knee-jerk
reaction was that this was just another
edgy anime that just pushed the boundary
even further than before if you're a
regular viewer of my content you all
know that edgy or fan service and anime
has been getting more and more extreme
slowly over the years but to me there's
always been a clear distinction between
edgy and hentai and that is well sex no
matter how much nudity there was or
kinky [__] that was happening Edie was
always about pushing the boundary as
much as possible without showing full
intercourse or having it even happen off
screen and as such the biggest
differentiation in terms of approach is
that edgy comedies always came from the
perspective of horny teenagers trying to
get laid and the jokes would be centered
around that while this show on the other
hand is about grown-ass men who are
actively getting laid and you know what
I totally think there should be more
edgy anime centered around sex sex can
be a hilarious topic that seems somewhat
taboo in anime for some reason so it
already feels Marvel's different from
your typical edgy anime but regardless I
think the line is that don't just tackle
the topic of sex but show it too which
brings it more into the world of hentai
right and this is where the line gets a
bit blurry anyone who's seen the
uncensored version of episode 3 will see
that yep that's definitely sex I know
what sex looks like probably be clear
there have been sex scenes in anime
before but most of these are not shows
that aired on TV and none have come even
remotely close to being as explicit or
depicting how sex looks in your typical
hentai which includes many traits any
fellow degenerate might recognize such
as
[Music]
squirty squirty dildo penetration
penetration tentacle esque bondage and
intercourse climaxing with a gal faces
that's ramming using [__] and of course
the good old hentai stomach bulge pretty
much the only thing that was missing was
full pixelated genitals and obligatory
x-ray shots and some fat ugly bastard
appearing out of nowhere for every anime
girl within a ten-mile radius to be like
hey Vsauce Michael here come on in so
you can make a very strong case that it
is a hentai but at the end of the day
what's really matters is am I going to
watch this
to you know start beating that meat
shaking hands with the governor making
the board man cry sending out the truths
whack in the Kraken choking out Charlie
aren't Turing the bone of partner and
there may sound contradictory coming
from the same man that once said how can
I say this you definitely can but let's
be real here there are far better things
you can put on if you want something for
that sole intent which is exactly what
hentai is made for in the same way I
don't go on Twitter for the sole intent
of seeing lewd anime girls but I
appreciate the fact that they appear on
my timeline anyway the sex scenes to me
still serve the purpose outside of
getting some peepees hard but if it's
not an edgy anime and it's not a full
hentai then what is it and this is why I
found myself far more attached this show
than I thought I would be as someone
who's been watching anime for quite a
long time one thing I've really
cherished nowadays is whenever I get to
experience something new even if I can
see the inherent flaws in a show or it's
not exactly the peak of anime I can hold
something in much higher regard if I get
to experience something I never have
before I hold your name really dear to
my heart because it was the first truly
anime cinematic experience I got to see
in theaters re-creators will never be
topped for the most fun
at a time of had as an anime fan and now
interspecies reviewers has also joined
those same ranks of showing me something
new
because to me this isn't an edgy comedy
nor is it a glorified porno with a plot
this is the very first hentai sitcom
it's something that clearly resides in
the same world and rules you see in him
tie but not something that feels like it
was made with the same intent
essentially he's following a bunch of
funny bros who found themselves in an
episode of a hentai the sex scenes
aren't the main reason to watch it but
it's totally natural to have them
because it sets in a hentai
but I don't want you to think that just
because it dare to set a comedy in a
hence I'd love it's worth taking note of
because there is more to it than just
that the comedy doesn't come from a
simple place of shocking or or hey guys
look how much we're pushing the boundary
it's sex jokes with that you're sexing
it when it comes from someone who quite
clearly understands the hentai culture
there is way more substance than there
should be in a show about a bunch of
dudes banging monster girls because okay
real talk for a second here guys I have
never felt someone connect with my
degeneracy as much as I have watching
this show
if satirizes elements of hem tired just
as much as it celebrates a to hell even
[__] looks like one tell me the our
style and animation especially during
the juicier scenes dare remind you of
something like your case or Sookie bear
elf no more da or anything else made by
bunny Walker but that's what I love
about this show the comedy itself might
not be the funniest I've ever seen but
it scratches this itch I didn't know I
had for hantai not hentai content each
episode has the guys going to new
brothel to bang a bunch of new species
of monster girls and what I find
entertaining doesn't so much come from
the punchline of one-liners though it
definitely has them but the sheer
audacity and realization that someone
has put this much passion and thought
into their degeneracy there has been
genuine thoughts put into the smallest
degenerate detail from what different
species value in their sexual
preferences to the completely unique
sexual experience every brothel and
every species has with no discrimination
for race gender age or type Cyclops
Valley females with massive eyes rather
than massive tits elves have a thing for
old human women because they still are
way younger than younger looking elves
species have an overall popularity of
who is most dateable it has more
effective world building than most
fantasy shows that take place in the
same kind of setting which is not what
you would expect for a show like this
and that's why I can't even call the sex
scenes gratuitous because they help
paint a better picture what the
experience is like with every new
species
it's literally great [__] world
building this is all coming from someone
who's obviously watched way too much
hentai Nazz able to come up with a
ridiculous scenarios and jokes that only
those well-versed and its rules would be
able to appreciate like okay
imagine you have a room full of succubus
succubus suck you buy whatever you know
the whole concept of a succubus sounds
cool until you find us they will
literally not stop [__] you until you
die you are risking your life just by
entering that room what's the only
things that can combat such evil oh I
know how about a little army of fat ugly
bastards
how is that not genius these stories
feel like the shower force you keep to
yourself until you're up drunk at 3:00
a.m. with the boys and you've somehow
found yourself creating a
tearless for hentai tags or arguing with
each other about the intimate logistics
that actually goes into having sex with
a slime girl and you conclude that the
slime girl would hopefully have precise
control over the pressure and
temperature of the slime inside her body
to simulate vaginal penetration so it
doesn't just feel like you're sticking
your dick in cold flaccid jelly and then
you wake up the next day and never
mention the conversation again because
no one in the functional society needs
to know that you had that conversation
that's what it feels like watching this
show it is the literal definition of me
and the boys hang out in a hentai so if
you're not someone who's invested in the
finer details of this art form known as
hentai you probably won't find this show
very appealing and yeah that's
everything worth mentioning about
interspecies reviewers all right all
right
a lot of the conversation about
interspecies reviews has been around the
situation surrounding it and everyone
has already put the two cents in so I
don't want to spend too much time on it
all this started off to episode 3 and
Funimation announced that they were
dropping it because it fell outside of
their company standards do I agree with
their decision not necessarily I mean
I've just spent a whole video arguing
about the merits of the show but do I
understand yeah episode 3 pushed the
boundary more than any TV anime ever has
before and if a season degenerate like
me thinks it's basically hentai then
[__] how the hell are other people
supposed to see it cuz this hasn't been
an isolated incident
either it's also been poured off Amazon
and now two separate TV channels in
Japan so do I think it's a shame that
this show is getting pulled off left
right and center of every service no I
think it's [__] hilarious
like after episode 3 aired I just
imagine a bunch of guys sitting in a
boardroom in silence as they are
watching a transformed demi-human
getting a dildo shoved up their arse
from behind and as the moans echo across
the meeting room one guy finally muscles
up the courage to say guys guys guys
guys guys guys
this pawn
oh god what have we done I should
probably mention quickly that he was one
of the top-rated anime on my anime list
for a short period of time thanks to
anime youtuber Lux Taku campaigning
everyone to have vote it there you go
honestly I think the whole discussion
with interspecies reviewers has been
more around the controversy surrounding
it than the show itself and I think
that's a shame because I am having a
great time with the show and I don't
want people to get the impression that
the only thing has going for it is memes
and controversy this was a genuinely new
experience for me with a lot of passion
being put into something I never thought
I'd see be put into and given the
controversy that this show has gone
through I don't know if we will ever get
to see another show like this again I
honestly have to give props to the anima
team for how far they had the balls to
take this because if you didn't know
there were no sex scenes in the manga in
fact you didn't even get nipple there
was no way for the TV stations to know
what they were getting into because none
of the most explicit stuff was even in
the source material but you know what I
think they made the product better in a
plot that quite clearly took place in a
hentai world they aspired to turn that
vision into our reality during an era
where we hear about an anime adaptation
announcement and we think to ourselves
man I wonder how much they are gonna
censor from the manga this time these
mad lads these pioneers of degeneracy
went oh they took down hentai Haven no
worries in 2020 every anime site can be
hentai haven you get hentai and you get
hentai and you get hentai cute girls
doing cute things means now is the time
for
men doing old ship things but you know
if TV anime is pushing the boundaries
this much man I can't even begin to
imagine what's going on in the world of
hentai right now meanwhile in the world
of hentai
[Music]
what up [__] hey guys Giga care hope you
enjoyed the video thank you very much -
crossing void for being mad lads and
coming back and sponsoring me today even
though this time I didn't actually talk
about any of their IPs and I was like
hey how do you feel about sponsoring
definitely not hentai content they're
also running a special giveaway right
now you can win Miku Expo 2020 tickets
limited Hatsune Miku series acrylic
stands and a nest here hats named Miku
character in the game by just going to
their Facebook and Twitter and sharing
their post or the info you need is
available in the description so yeah if
you want to try out crossing void today
click the link below to download it on
iOS or Android and with that said thank
you very much to Robert on Bourg Walter
Bob Munden we've ologist Ricky changed
later and everyone else on my patreon
for helping to sponsor me today and look
whether you consider interspecies
reviewer a hentai or not an anime or an
IDI that has pushed the boundary further
than any show ever has before it doesn't
matter because YouTube's gonna be
monetize this video anyway so if you
want to support more content on big
anime titties and the men of culture who
pursue such dreams then consider
becoming a patreon and I would certainly
appreciate that anyway that's it for me
today no further updates I've been
gigging and I will see you all next time